[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to another
mukbang blah blah blah Blau now last
week we had Joe experiment and try my
[ __ ] tea sushi [ __ ] as you can tell
I've been cooking all day which is why
I'm greasy I'm hot and I had this sexy
little tank top on for you which means
that in today's mukbang I will not be
eating the food guess who will be eating
it yes we're talking about that anime
cutie little freak Julia chow
Wow now because I know Julia loves anime
I decide to make an anime dish now if
you're wondering what dish we're going
to make is from a very very very
well-known classic called Naruto I
respect every single ramen chef out
there now because I didn't realize how
much it takes to create a bowl of ramen
a lot of people out there will complain
about oh my god well it's not a bowl of
pasta [ __ ] [ __ ] Italian pasta is
easy to make making ramen Oh without
further ado I introduce to you Julia
ciao ciao hello everyone I'm Julia chow
aka X blue apples I'm not too hard to
please actually I am very easygoing when
it comes to food but I can tell when
food is gross and nasty and bad but I
trust David because he makes the most
delicious food ever all the time I think
I've really enjoyed his mac and cheese
that he made for Thanksgiving
what else did he make oh um he also I
don't know I just get so excited because
like David always makes delicious food
and I don't doubt that whatever he
brings is going to be delicious this is
kind of interesting this right here
mm-hmm I know it looks very mundane but
I had leftover sashimi so I left over
Toto and yellow denim and we made us
nothing for this and instead of regular
nori this is actually crazy with this
toasted with sesame oil mmm YUM
hmm there is bomb the seaweed is nicely
toasted rice has a great texture hmm and
the leftover sashimi is so good no I
just want another one
can i yeah so what I put in it
mm-hmm so there's yellowtail belly
there's tutorial which is medium fat
tuna we put a little green onions in
there yeah some sweet Maui onions a
little bit of like soy sauce sesame oil
I put a pocket is that all together you
know David I don't know I'm typically
not like a huge fan of like yellowtail
and like tuna cuz I'm usually standing
all the way but you make does taste
really good so this is my version of
Naruto's ichiraku ramen really yeah so
here you have the marinated a soft boil
uh-huh have in-house marinated Menma
green onions not a Tamaki of course pork
do you don't know how much I started
salivating like like literally
everything is just moist and wet in my
mouth I decided to do a triple broth so
this is actually a Sheila ramen so the
main flavor component is salt okay but I
did this with a dashi that I made
in-house mm-hmm
she had talked in mushroom broth and
then I did all my favorite things like
literally my first type of ramen I had
washio ramen it was like the best ramen
I've ever had and then the fact that you
put mush in there cuz I like mushrooms I
like chicken broth and then the dashi is
cool too first you smell is what I hear
you smell and then they taste a broth
but I don't really care I just like hope
so excited
okay you know it doesn't taste too oily
or fatty hmm it's not overly salty mmm
good flavor next noodles I was told you
should slurp your noodles all the time
so I'm gonna do that mmm I'm so nice and
chewy because I know some ramen places
like they they like undercooked their
noodles and it doesn't taste that good
but this is really good mmm
did you make that bamboo yourself David
it has a good crunch to it because most
times when I eat bamboo shoots are like
already kind of soggy you're like limp
mmm
next
I'm gonna eat this mmm
love it Oh parents please David know I'm
like blue like this is absolutely
delicious I just want to cry right now
cuz it's so good the pork is um it's not
as tender as to what I'm used to at
least a fatty area yeah it's it's tashi
pork what I see beat it so it's still
pork belly that bit where it's not like
completely fall apart I still melt
nicely in the mouth though I don't know
about you guys but personally I don't
like cooked egg yolk I feel it's just
nasty it's powdery to the grouse but
when eggs are cooked like this or when
it is raw it's absolutely delicious so
good I feel like there's a lot more
flavor in it and it's a lot more
bearable to eat so I'm just gonna taste
this
I really like the broth not too salty
very savory not fatty at all
mmm I'm gonna add this soup in here I
think the first time that I actually had
a JIT ramen was I think in high school
and I just remember at that time there
weren't that many ramen places or at
least I didn't know of any at the time
the first one I had was a Shia base
because when i when i read show you and
i said it was like a soy sauce base soup
i was like oh i don't want to drink soy
sauce so I went with the co because I
thought hey why not like maybe this is
how ROM is supposed to be like right had
it I thought was absolutely great up
until I had a different ramen which was
called Tampopo
and it used to be in Diamond Plaza off
of Fullerton Road their ramen was pretty
good but then but then when I had oh my
gosh what was it when I had Shinsengumi
that felt like a huge upgrade because I
never knew that tonkotsu broth was a
thing like pork bone soup what got into
noodles so eating this reminds me a lot
of the time when I watched Naruto for
some odd reason every time I finished
tennis camp over the summer I would just
walk home and every time I walked home I
was always thinking of like one of the
the theme songs or like the opening or
the ending song I don't remember I
remember for some reason it would always
be stuck in my head as I'm walking home
and it always made me crave ramen so my
typical morning I guess as after tennis
camp I would walk home get home make
some ramen and then watch an episode of
Naruto Naruto always made it look so
delicious to eat Robin so you can
imagine how stoked I was when I actually
had real
[Music]
[Music]
I can't help but make this face when you
feed me something and I go mmm you know
that's a good sign because I can't
control that I can't control at all look
at this meat it's nicely soaked in hmm
all in the mouth mmm after eating in a
meal you always have to have dessert
because there's always a room for
dessert always there's this anime if you
guys don't know called Cardcaptor Sakura
in the recent episode that they had the
main character is making this cheesecake
that her friend has her friend has this
Blom ass recipe for cheesecake and they
made it and just watching that made me
want to eat a cheesecake there's a lot
I'm gonna go get cheesecake later though
there we go
so this I clearly did it make but this
is me favorite dessert from uncle Tetsu
which is that fluffy Japanese cheesecake
that everybody loves everybody enjoys
this one is not the original cheesecake
that you normally get no it's actually
the coffee organ if you've ever had that
I can eat it now here we go
mm-hmm how perfect I was just talking
about cheesecake earlier mmm it's like a
very light texture but it's not heavy
but it's not as light as Asian
cheesecakes like most Asian cheesecake
that you would get at like any Asian
bakery but whew this is like nicely
thick enough but it's fluffy mmm and
it's moist that's very good
wanna bite David I will after
I think the first time I had this cake
was I think for your birthday
I think we were all bullying at this one
place in Highland Park and merio brought
it or something mm-hmm
oh so good I definitely enjoy eating
Japanese cheesecake than American
cheesecake
just because American cheesecake is very
heavy very thick and overly sweet like
Japanese cheesecake it's like nice light
fluffy but it's not like too fluffy like
a sponge cake it was not a really sweet
either All American desserts majority of
them are like oh really sweet and I have
no idea why they're overly sweet I think
if you could cut down the sugar in half
that would probably good sweetness of
American sweetness is here and if like
Asian sweetness is here I'm leaning more
towards like right here just this area
because I like it a little bit sweeter
but not too sweet yeah this is fun maybe
I should start doing multiplies you
should yeah I think people prefer when
girls do both thumbs over guys yeah
things expected what a big guy just eats
poop what a little cute girl eats a lot
of food that's what they really want to
see I mean I enjoy eating food thank you
guys for watching I mean what you
muffled okay so just to let you know
it's a hundred percent experimental so I
never really tried to like what my food
was experimental - so it doesn't matter
okay oh I'm excited yeah the first time
I had mochi waffles was at MJ cafe and
it freaking blew my mind what is that MJ
cafe is like a tea place yeah it's a tea
place so they have like these like
fishbowl like boba teas and stuff like
that and they have like desserts and one
of the desserts is mochi waffle I
personally like mochi waffles a lot just
because I like mochi rice flour already
has a de suite as to it so you don't
need to actually add too much sugar to
it as well okay look see I feel I was
missing a few ingredients okay I'm
missing vanilla
it tastes like trash and I'm missing ice
cream well maybe like a honey drizzle
light would be good
I think I hope it's sweet enough oh
that's a good crunch you don't need
anything else is pretty [ __ ] good is
it number one you get that crunchiness
that you get from a traditional waffle
and a Belgian waffle but you get that
that mochi / like Korean thug doing this
on the middle
mm-hmm-hmm yeah hey mom I think for me I
might I think I would prefer to have it
be a little bit more crispy it's a
little bit of that sweet banana
yeah tart fresh strawberry
there's the whipped cream - mmm we're
gonna use it bonito therefore I even
brought out a knife - but yeah yeah I
love what you like waffles or pancakes
really maybe one day I'll master it well
you could go ahead and spit on me all oh
you [ __ ] that's pretty [ __ ] good
oh thank you thank you thank you that's
it for this book bong put in the
comments below who else you want me to
bring on here and make sure there's
people that I liked it was people I
[ __ ] hate but not eat my food and if
I do like them most likely I'm gonna
poison them so haha or bring me back
again
yes see y'all next time
[Music]